hi my name is Philip Lyman and I'm still
alive I'm at Fairfield University
I have migrated a few days and we'll be
talking about computational mindfulness
the idea is can you become more mindful
by doing certain things such as spot the
difference images ranging in difficulty
or looking at quantum randomness as
opposed to regular pseudo randomness
good morning we're here to talk about
computational mindfulness now I'm Philip
Lyman this my daughter Stella my man
you may have heard of mindfulness
mindfulness is the new hotness you have
you heard the phrase mindfulness you've
heard what it's talking about now this
is not a neuroscience lecture as you can
tell by the apparent lack of fMRI
machines and it's not a meditation
retreat as you could tell by the
complete lack of yoga mats we'll talk
about mindfulness and how we've thought
about approaching it in terms of a
computational way but mainly through the
perspective of wolfram tools and
technologies that's the the main focus
here mindfulness typically when you
think about mindfulness the usual
definition is that it's something that
you can get after 40 years of learning
how to meditate
so you've meditated for 40 years and you
have two minutes of mindfulness good
deal an alternative approach or prepared
by Ellen Langer who's been referred to
as the mother of mindfulness is that
mindfulness is very simple it's just the
process the active process of noticing
new things if you look around the room
now if you notice three new things
boom you're mindful end of story so
instant mindfulness like that that's
what we want to look at the benefits of
mindfulness which we've learned over the
past 40 years have included virtually
anything you can think of health mental
health relationships love career
earnings you name it let's look at how
so when entering a new field when
looking at what what research has been
done before it's useful to see just the
some numbers like how much mindfulness
has grown so I'm always a little bit
behind the times I've been concatenated
strings like a sucker for for many years
but string template is much nicer what I
weigh to think of string template is it
returns a function and then you just
call the parameters 1 2 whatever you
want
so 4 we want to take the look at Google
Scholar and see how many articles were
published on mindfulness in a particular
year so 2019 or 2019 for example the
only problem if we run import on it
Google seems to identify that we're not
really a justifiable human being and and
doesn't let us do it this is one of the
nice new features in Mathematica you can
control a browser directly
programmatically and have it do all your
work for you now the only problem is if
I run this it's sometimes
and sometimes doesn't the only reason it
doesn't is Google become suspicious and
starts asking us to prove that we're
human and I am really bad at those so
let's just I'll tell you what the
numbers were from before and then when
you're done you just close the object
delete the option this way so here's
what the can you see those numbers this
is what the article's counts for
mindfulness has been like since 1960
it's rare to find an exponential chart
as beautiful as this right so the last
one the last point is this year 2019
it's a little down but okay it's not the
full year 2018 the point before and 2017
the mark one marked in X maybe we have
reached peak mindfulness ladies and
gentlemen its it's all downhill from
here but there's there's good news so
here's the good news
so as Ellen Langer says if mindfulness
is the simple act of noticing new things
can we induce mindfulness with a spot
the difference challenge does anyone see
the difference between this image on the
left and the edited image on the right
the top is missing in the second image
so the heart of all this functionality
is image content which guesses so it
finds the bounding boxes of contents in
the image and guess is what it think it
what it thinks it is so although most of
these are wrong like this ice cream is a
hot dog this one's a cake and these two
are umbrellas that doesn't really matter
for my purposes because all I need are
the bounding boxes to either edit them
out or just take the content out
completely here are some of the image
edit functions that I've created for a
spot the difference challenges here's an
example of the image map all function
you can see in these images there's one
butterfly missing the bottom the bottom
one and the first one here is missing
and then the top one right here
and the big one in the middle over here
has been expunged
so this is the website that I made in
this past summer at the wolf from high
school summer camp you choose the
difficulty if you want all of the images
in that difficulty range or just one
randomly chosen one and an image so here
is an example DG so you can see it will
show you the demonstration live you'll
see my brainwave so those are my
brainwaves you so I'll try to I can't
seem to calm down but when I blink
you'll see it ready see the blinks
that's life okay
walk us through the experiment okay so
these are the easy one but because there
are so many contents it's harder to find
the differences
does anyone see the difference between
this image and the one on the right yep
and then right here is the image
difference so it shows us that we are
correct
does anyone see that it moves between
these two
where is it nice job will do one more
does anyone see the difference between
these two
subtle top where top middle alright yeah
that's pretty metal yeah so it's the
plan right here oh nice to see the white
background alright so let's look at the
brainwave and we export it this is we're
using a brain bit but we're we're gonna
try to export it later signal okay okay
okay so this is an EEG it measures
brainwaves electrical activity and uses
these disks here's what was just
measured on this line plot here's what I
looked like
so we'll basically take the average of
these four and across various trials and
that'll represent my brain activity as
these are the four sensors so here's our
first hypothesis that when you're doing
difficult spot the difference challenges
and her website has ranges from easy to
impossible impossible literally is
impossible it's like the microscopic
changes that even computers can't detect
they can detect the weekend we presume
suppose you're looking at different spot
the difference is some of them are easy
right there's just a big fish missing
fine and some of them are much more
subtle we assumed we deemed that when
you're looking at the easy ones you're
kind of being mindless but when you're
looking at the difficult ones then
you're being mindful you're noticing new
things here's an example of what that
would look like okay Oh a quick aside
there is a way to create web apps on
using wolfram this is pretty unknown
thing so let me show you how to do it it
uses something called Jason net or Jason
L can you see this can you see that
great so I'm mirroring my iPhone so this
is an app called Jason net it works it's
it's a single app that can you can make
a JSON file that's your entire
app and it creates local web UI
components both for Android and iOS so
here's the existing app that I have this
is a mindfulness app that if I'm Co
building with my partner's Peter lien
Chan Ho Park and Ellen Langer and and
this is all done you can the source code
is basically here when you have JSON you
should think Association so it's just
associations now the amazing thing is
look I'll make a new code we'll add this
welcome to Wolfram up top it creates
this QR code and can you see mine here
we'll just scan the QR code for the new
source okay found it and there you can
see at the top it says welcome to
Wolfram we just changed the source code
for an app live without going through
the App Store without going through
anything now imagine if these components
there they're pretty they're fine what's
built into JSON adder what's called
Jason L now you could do pretty cool
things with it that's no problem but
imagine if this could also communicate
with the local Wolfram kernel in your
iPhone all the amazing things that you
could do then
for example this mandala I didn't write
the code for this as I got it from Stack
Exchange I think it was written by Anton
Anton of it's beautiful but imagine how
much more amazing it could be if we
could also integrate with Wolfram with
the Wolfram kernel which it can do this
is all totally possible and Jason ed is
entirely open source so we could be we
could use it that way ok great now I'm
about to tell you something that is the
most ridiculous assertion the craziest
hypothesis you'll ever hear I'm I'm a
little embarrassed to tell you in fact
the only other people on earth who know
this hypothesis so far are my daughter
my wife her mother and our rabbi so but
we're among friends now we're not even
among friends Wolfram is a family were
among family would feel like we're in a
safe place so I'll tell you our
ridiculous hypothesis and it's this
weirdoes mindfulness comfort why does
mindfulness work why does noticing new
things cause all these amazing health
benefits it's a crazy assertion
even crazier would be this assertion
that it all has to do with quantum
mechanics so when you measure an
electron or a photon and you know which
branch your honor it before you measure
it's in the superposition is kind of
everywhere the same way if your mindless
world is kind of hazy but when you see
where it is then you're on a particular
branch and you become mindful you're on
a particular branch I know this is a
ridiculous assertion because subatomic
particles which is the basis of quantum
mechanics has nothing to do with the
macroscopic things that we're seeing
when we're looking for new things new
nice dress nice shoes what a brilliant
new car that has nothing to do with
subatomic particles right I get it I
know it's ridiculous but let's test it
so we're gonna test it
so not just computational mindfulness
but quantum computational mindfulness
here's our second hypothesis that if you
look at random numbers you'll be
mindless but if you look at quantum
random numbers then you'll be mindful
ridiculous right totally ridiculous but
here's where we'll try it so to get
pseudo random numbers we'll use rule xxx
standard cellular automata here's how it
looks like so these random numbers here
they're each of these points is
something between white and black it's
and on a scale of 0 to 15 it's the same
thing as you could use with random image
but we'll use this because we can then
send in different quantum randomness so
far so good if you're looking at that
then unless you're doing something else
you're probably mindless that's the
claim now if we do quantum random
numbers there is a website in Australia
that you can ping and it'll give you
live quantum random numbers and if you
don't ping then they just discard those
numbers they don't exist so this one you
ate it live for you so here we go you
are now about to be entangled with a
bunch of there we go you're entangled
with a bunch of electrons and protons
from photons from Australia how does it
feel hopefully a little bit mindful yes
yes if like if you do a beam splitter
right and a electron could go to the
left or it could go to the right this
would be a zero this would be a one so
in a many-worlds interpretation both
things happen right and there you're
half of you same you but I will sort of
half the weight goes on one branch half
of you go
the other branch that make sense as
opposed to pseudo-random numbers which
are just computer algorithms like the
rule 30 cellular automata the the reason
quantum the reason quantum random
numbers might make more sense is if it's
something underlying there's no the
quantum measurement problem is the
biggest problem in quantum mechanics
right nobody knows why why measuring
something would collapse it so there's
different interpretations the
many-worlds interpretation says there is
no collapse as branches of you you
become duplicate copies whatever however
you want to think about it the fact is
once you once you see something the
structure of that subatomic particle
changes completely it loses its
superposition it's no longer interesting
it just becomes there is there the
electron shorting curse cat is either
dead or alive once you look at it
doesn't continue to exist in a
superposition in other words would
become entangled with it and or you can
say it dqo here's what the environment
however you want to think about it we're
now there right in other words we are
here and not there that's the same thing
as being mindful you notice the
differences you notice new things that
you didn't notice before okay so what
are the results
that's the thin blue line here it's very
volatile my volatility is 275 just
bouncing around when I was looking at
the harder ones I was closer my ee g's
were closer to an almost straight line
which we think of as the most mindful
state you can see from my dad - although
he's a bit more volatile in both when
looking at the hard images he's much
closer to that again that straight line
and when I was looking at the random
images and I was looking at rule 30 my
volatility was 483 and when I was
looking at the quantum random images it
dropped 200 and when my dad was looking
at them at the rule 30 it's very
volatile again and it's almost a perfect
straight line or he was looking at the
quantum images I think it's important to
note that because I made these spot the
difference images I had seen most of
them and there and although there is no
way I could have known all of the image
differences in the edited images I still
had an idea of what the contents were
and my father did not when I was looking
at the random images I did not know if
it was a rule 30 or if it was a quantum
but my
father did so maybe we could say that
not only looking at a quantum random
image but knowing you're looking at a
quantum image will make you more mindful
and if you take away nothing else from
this presentation each of this took us
maybe two minutes so if you can take two
minutes every day and just look at a
spot the difference image or create your
own quantum random image and just take
two minutes to have all those benefits
to love the relationships just happier
in general can you imagine what that
would do for our world thank you thank
you
[Applause]